[Music]
in huby halloween adam sandler stars as
salem's self-appointed official
volunteer halloween helper
whose job it is to make sure that
everyone has a safe and fun halloween
that's easier said than done all kinds
of sinister characters are wandering
around abducting salem residents and
causing some not-so-good-natured
mischief
if the city is going to survive this
halloween huby has his work cut out for
him
hey i'm home
not only does hubie halloween have
plenty of unexpected plot twists
and more surprise cameos than you can
possibly imagine
but it's also crammed full of small
details that bring its absurd version of
salem massachusetts to vibrant life
if you're a die-hard fan of sandler's
work or if you just love all hallows eve
qb halloween has lots for you to enjoy
here are a few spoiler-filled examples
from the ghostbusters theme song to shev
willie's the purple people eater to
warren zevon's classic werewolves of
london
qb halloween soundtrack is crammed full
of spine tingling tunes that'll get you
in the mood for hubie's signature day
still monster mash deserves some special
attention
not only does bobby pick its novelty hit
open and close the movie
but you'll see picket's 1962 record the
original monster mash hanging on the
wall of salem's local radio station wtch
the original monster match isn't the
only halloween adjacent album displayed
at wtch either
hanging next to that record you'll find
a copy of jackie wilson's higher and
higher
the title track of which features
prominently in ghostbusters 2.
you know the song that makes the statue
of liberty come to life and walk down
the streets of manhattan yep that's the
one
of course given huby halloween's setting
it makes sense for the local dj to keep
a few halloween themed tracks on hand
if you're going to make a movie about
halloween you'd be hard-pressed to find
a better setting than salem
massachusetts
qb halloween pays a lot of attention to
salem's troubling real-life past
look closely and you'll see witches all
over the place from the local radio
station
to cubies high school yearbook that's
not just a huby halloween creation
either
at the real life salem high school
witches have been the official mascots
for years
qb halloween doesn't just take place in
salem though
it was also filmed there and a few
prominent salem landmarks ended up
making their way into the film
the salem witch museum is probably the
most notable
established in 1972 the museum is
dedicated to educating the public about
life in colonial america
clearing up some of the misconceptions
surrounding the salem witch trials
history
so yes that's the actual museum you see
when hubie and violet reunite
if you study the scenery you may
actually learn a little history
as the museums display shows men were
tried for witchcraft in addition to
women
and the victims were hanged not burned
at the stake
huey halloween isn't a horror movie but
it's structured like one
and it has a lot of fun playing on
traditional horror movie tropes
as such it's only natural that hubie
halloween also pays tribute to some of
the classic horror movies that inspired
it
the kids who torment hubie wear ghost
face masks as made famous by the movie
scream
violet's oldest daughter watches the
creature from the black lagoon
mayor benson's refusal to cancel salem's
halloween festivities
which would deprive the city of sweet
tourism cash even though there's an
emergency unfolding
recalls the behavior of mayor larry
vaughn from jaws
you yell shark
we've got a panic on our hands on the
4th of july and when the residents of
salem take to the streets to party
many of them are dressed like
frankenstein's monster or vampires
or countless other movie creatures qb
halloween's best horror movie reference
however
is one that's remarkably easy to miss
after a person goes missing
cubie gives the sheriff the address of
walter lambert his mysterious next door
neighbor
where does he live 59 outfit check on it
there's your killer anyone who knows
anything about slasher movies could
catch the nut immediately
elm street is also the haunting grounds
of one freddy krueger
who made his feature film debut in
1984's a nightmare on elm street
and who went on to become one of the
most iconic horror villains ever
this time though freddy better watch out
with hubie on the case
not even supernatural dream hunters are
safe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't need to be familiar with adam
sandler's password to enjoy qb halloween
this holiday themed comedy was made for
everyone but
if you're an old school sandler fan
you'll find plenty of references to the
comedian's past work scattered
throughout the movie
not only is hubie halloween's cast
stacked with sandler's past
collaborators
but many of the jokes in the film are
called classic moments from the actors
past projects
[Music]
in fact there's even a bit of sandler's
stunt on saturday night live baked into
hubie halloween's dna
especially when it comes to huby himself
in a 1993 episode of snl
the comedian debuted canteen boy a 27
year old man who's still
inexplicably in the boy scouts canteen
boy was a big influence on bobby boucher
the hero of the waterboy and his legacy
lives on in hubie dubois too
[Laughter]
it's not just both characters permanent
state of arrested development
their heavy accents or their fondness
for beverage containers either
early in hubie halloween hubie mentions
that he built his thermos while he was a
scout
and his high school yearbook photo shows
him in full boy scout regalia
he still has a uniform too in a montage
a middle-aged to be burst into the
police station
still wearing his scout get-up huby and
canteen boy aren't the same of course
qb is kinder more heroic infinitely more
self-aware
and has much more psychological depth
still
if you want to close your eyes and
pretend that hubie is canteen boy all
grown up
it works surprisingly well to me that's
a great deal but it's also a riot
waiting to happen
eventually huby's investigation leads
into the local drive-in theater
where many of salem's residents are
enjoying a spooky double feature
cubie isn't there to watch a movie of
course he's looking for the person who
abducted mike mundy
still when the scene begins we get a
quick glimpse of the movies playing at
the outdoor theater
and one of them is very much an actual
film
well sort of anyway the version of i was
a teenage zombie that appears in hubie
halloween is a parody starring sketch
comedian martin herlihy as the titular
undead teen
frequent adam sandler and happy madison
collaborator alan covert as his father
and sandler's longtime assistant jd
donnarumma as the ill-fated milkman
however a real feature with the same
name came out in 1987.
that film begins like a typical 80s team
comedy about some kids trying to buy
marijuana
only to take a more horrific turn when
their drug dealer dies
they dump his body into a river
overflowing with toxic waste
thus bringing him back to life i was a
teenage zombie is a mostly amateur
effort
and it's mainly notable for its
soundtrack still if you like no budget
horror comedies
it's worth checking out just don't go
looking for the other half of the salem
drive-ins double feature
my hairy baby that one alas is pure
fantasy
hubie halloween is a comedy first and
foremost
but there's more than a little mystery
baked into its plot too
sub tries to figure out who's abducting
salem's residence
he runs across a number of suspects
there's his next-door neighbor walter
lambert
whose proclivities tend toward the
lycanthropic
okay halloween mickey walker
there's huby's childhood friend richie
lambert who recently escaped from the
nearby asylum and has made his way back
to his hometown
there's huby's longtime crush violet
valentine who shares the kidnappers love
of chardonnay
and there's hubie himself after all the
people who go missing all love to bully
the self-proclaimed halloween monitor
ultimately those are all red herrings
the real criminal ends up being cubie's
mother
who's simply trying to protect her sweet
little boy it's a twist ending
but there are a few hints throughout the
movie that modular is behind the whole
thing
early on huby needs help opening a jar
of frosting
his mother handles it with ease yes
that's a joke about how weak cubie is
but it's also an indication that cubie's
mother is phenomenally strong for her
age
a trait she needs if she's going to
adopt multiple full-grown adults
you can also see that her mask is
different from richie hartman's
while the asylum resident wears a pig
mask with round eyes
the point of view shots that appear
during the abduction scenes feature
triangle-shaped eye holes
letting us know that hartman isn't the
culprit
for long time adam sandler fans it's a
real treat seeing him reunite with ed
and modern family star julie bowen
who plays hubie's love interest violet
valentine 24 years ago
bowen starred with sandler in happy
gilmore which was her feature film debut
in that movie bowen played virginia
bennett head of the pro golf tour's pr
team
and love interest to sandler's happy
bowen also joined a tradition that's
followed sandler through many of his
movies
including qb halloween quite often
sandler's on-screen romantic partners
have the initials vv
there's violet and virginia of course
but that's just the beginning
in billy madison the first movie that
sandler headlined
bridget wilson plays veronica vaughn a
teacher who helps billy when he
re-enrolls in elementary school as an
adult
in the waterboy farouza balk stars as
vicki valencourt
an ex-con and bobby boucher's long-time
crush
patricia arquette shows up in little
nikki as valerie varan
a design student who falls for sandler's
son of satan
qb halloween is a very funny movie with
an appropriately happy ending
but it hits a somber note right before
the credits roll if you watch the movie
through to the very end
you'll find a brief but extremely
heartfelt tribute to cameron boyce
a young and very talented actor who
passed away unexpectedly in july 2019.
if you're familiar with boyce it's
probably through his work on the disney
channel where he was already a major
star
some of boyce's earliest roles include
guest appearances on disney sitcoms
and he later spent four seasons on jesse
where he co-starred alongside fellow
disney channel mainstay debbie ryan
and hubie halloween's very own payton
list boyce went on to lead disney xd's
gamer's guide to pretty much everything
in which he played a former esports pro
known as kid fury
but it was disney's descendants
franchise that really put him on the map
in that series voice appeared as carlos
the son of 101 dalmatians big bad
corella deville in addition to all his
disney work
voice was also part of the happy madison
family in grown-ups and grown-ups too
boyce appeared as keith fetter son of
adam sandler's linney and some high ex
roxanne
even with a cast as stacked as grown-ups
boyce managed to steal every scene he
was in
that was awesome it's only fitting that
the happy madison crew pays tribute to
the young actor
he's greatly missed check out our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you